the russia ukraine conflict russia has
650 billion dollars or so of foreign
reserves uh and also gold
what happens now that the united states
and allies have decided to kick russian
banks off of swift seas and freeze
foreign uh reserves etc like what are
the implications of the sanctions that
we're watching play out right now well
look as far as the broader you know big
picture long-term implications and and
what it really
portends for the dollar because i've
thought the dollars days as the primary
reserve currency were numbered anyway
uh but
this simply
highlights the
you know the risks that other countries
take
by basically relying on the us dollar
and turning over the global financial
system
to the us and just kind of allowing the
dollar to sit at at the top of this
system which gives tremendous power to
the united states not only in that
americans get to live well beyond their
means
we could print money and buy stuff and
it's a lot harder to make stuff than
print money i mean anybody can print
money
as long as people are willing to accept
it but producing goods quality goods
requires a lot of resources you need
capital which means you need savings you
you need skilled workers so
a lot goes into that and all we do is
you know just create numbers on a
computer
and we get to enjoy all these goods our
trade deficits right now are just
through the roof they are all-time
record highs we're doing over 100
billion a month in merchandise trade
deficits none of this would be possible
but for the dollar's reserve currency
status but right now you have a
situation where
russia is being punished you know
whether they deserve to be punished or
not is a completely a different argument
i'm not trying to defend what putin is
doing i'm just pointing out that if
you're another country or you're china
for example
and you're looking at the way uh
uh russia is being punished and you're
thinking i don't want to be in that
situation i don't want to be vulnerable
i don't want to
tie a noose around my neck and throw the
other end of the us and hope they don't
they don't yank it
uh so china's probably thinking we need
to get rid of a lot of these us dollars
we need to you know hurry up and get
away from this system get away from all
of these transactions that are in u.s
dollars so we're not dependent on that
ability to access these networks and you
know the chinese are sitting on
trillions trillions of dollars in
reserves a lot of it invested in u.s
treasuries i mean what if the u.s
government decides that it doesn't like
something that china's doing and oh
we're not going to pay you we're going
to default on the treasures that you own
or we're going to freeze
your assets so
i think this is just going to accelerate
the movement out of the dollar
which is going to bring forward the huge
problem you know ben um jerome powell
mentioned the other day at his uh
conference hearings in front of congress
somebody asked him you know what would
it mean for the u.s if the dollar was no
longer the world reserve currency and
his response was well you'd barely
notice the difference
which shows you how little he
understands
the benefits that are derived to the
united states from enjoying that
privilege and how dramatically our
standard of living would collapse if
that privilege were to be withdrawn hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time